[Music]
SpongeBob SquarePants is one of the most
popular animated series on Nickelodeon a
study even found that it made
preschoolers slower thinkers as it has
an impact on abstract thinking impulse
control and short-term memory but there
are plenty of other reasons why you
shouldn't let your kid watch this show
make sure you watch this video until the
end to see the most terrible thing
plankton ever did if you think that you
are old enough to see this if you love
SpongeBob SquarePants as much as we do
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up today we
are showing you 10 SpongeBob SquarePants
episodes that weren't for kids the plays
the thing this episode started in the
strangest light and this is probably
what makes it one of the most
inappropriate jokes on the show the
mailman went to the Krusty Krab to give
a letter to Squidward but spongebob
realized that he was the only one in the
restaurant his coworker wasn't there yet
how can he not be at his post at the
Krusty Krab there should always be
someone at the cache this is why he blew
a couple of balloons and sculpted them
to make it look like Squidward but as he
was holding it in his hand it just
looked like he was blowing a bunch of
condoms and it looked even worse when
one of them grew up to be the size of
you know what we're talking about
balloons are usually much more colorful
so why did spongebob have condoms in his
pocket he doesn't have any girlfriend
anyway our favorite character turn their
condoms into his coworker while the
mailman was looking at him confused it
just got worse when Squidward's nose
deflated spongebob was so bad at
pretending that he was Squidward that
the poor mailman just ran away screaming
this is what happens when you play with
condoms in public people think that you
are weird let the kids play with real
balloons instead demolition doofus and
this episode spongebob had to go to
class again because as we all know he
never learned how to drive everything
was going wrong and mrs. puff got bigger
and bigger no matter how hard spongebob
tried to do his best
she was so stressed that she exploded
and it is only in the hospital that mrs.
puff found out that she ruptured her
inflation fact and she will never puff
again spongebob tried to make her laugh
by saying that they would have to call
him mrs. puff
now we all knew that she wouldn't be
laughing at this joke but it just got
worse mrs. puff jumped on SpongeBob and
tried to strangle him with murder in her
eyes the animators tried to make it
funny
by making the sponge say that it tickles
but mrs. puff was so angry that the
doctor actually had to stop her she
wasn't feeling better the day after as
she fantasized on many ways spongebob
could die like by being hit by many cars
at the same time as she actually tried
to make that happen by making him
participate in a demolition derby we
don't know about you but we think that a
teacher trying to kill her student is
really inappropriate kids must have been
traumatized after seeing that what will
happen if they feel their driving class
to squid Ville in this episode spongebob
and patrick received new roof blowers
and they decided to have fun with it
this gadget couldn't only blow but also
suck which sounds really inappropriate
when you say it out loud anyway they
decided to suck some parts of
Squidward's house including the nose of
his house and the windows their neighbor
was upset so they tried to fix it but
destroyed his house instead this is why
Squidward decided to move far away from
them in squid Ville with other people
like him they all had the same house the
same interests and mostly the same
things that they disliked however there
is also one thing that we really hated
about them they were racist the only
species allowed to live in this place
where squids before he entered he was
asked if he was or had ever been a
sponge or a star he had to confirm that
he was a squid to have the right to
enter it just makes us think of the
neighborhoods in America that don't
accept people of color because yes it
does exist Squidward was proud to be
among his own kind but we think that
this kind of place should never be
portrayed in a good way our favorite
squid ended up missing his old
neighborhood so he left and we think
that this is the best decision he ever
made but we think that the other squids
should have learned a lesson too squid
Bob tentacle pants in this episode sandy
invented a new gadget that allowed
teleportation spongebob wanted to try it
to go to work faster but he ended up
right where Squidward was with his arm
in his mouth then the two co-workers
were teleported back which created a new
creature that we could call squid bub
tentacle pants it was the most terrible
thing that could happen to Squidward as
he was getting ready for his recital the
day after and this occasion was really
important for him but we think that he
was even more scared when spongebob said
that it means that they could be best
friends forever
this is why they went back into the
teleportation machine and terrified
everyone in the neighborhood as their
two bodies were mixed together they
terrified the kids at school a new mom
at the hospital and even seduced the
aliens but those who were the most
terrified where the kids at home
watching
SpongeBob SquarePants that's because
this episode was inspired by a horror
movie called the fly that only grownup
should watch we don't know about you but
we think that watching a disgusting
monster is not the best way to start
your day before school it could have
been a Halloween special but there is no
way this scary episode was made for kids
Jerry takes a bath in this episode it
was that time of the week again Carrie
had to take a bath but the snail was not
interested in going into the tub Sponge
Bob tried to play fetch by throwing a
ball in the bathtub but the ball came
back then he tried to scare the poor
Gary by saying that a bomb would explode
if he didn't take bath and the pet
couldn't care less playing leapfrog
didn't work either just like offering
money but when he tried to assault his
mind with subliminal messages spongebob
shared a little too much of his thoughts
he thought about the bathtub the shower
the soap and then suddenly there was a
girl laughing in his mind it had gone
too far and spongebob said sorry you had
to see that obviously this is a kids
cartoon so they couldn't show a really
beautiful girl
they should have kind of weird but
really funny girl instead but grown-ups
all knew what happened in SpongeBob's
mind and this is exactly the reason why
they don't want people to read their
mind let's say that according to the
myth men think about this every 7
seconds and spongebob is not an
exception anyway kids probably didn't
get this joke so this episode wasn't
that bad that's a good reason to watch
Spongebob Squarepants again as grown-ups
pet or pests once again spongebob and
patrick we're trying to have fun but
when it turned out wrong they said that
they should try to do something that
requires less thinking they found a ball
that they wanted to play with until they
realized that it was actually a living
creature
spongebob was scared but Patrick thought
that the worm was really nice this is
why they invited him to stay at
SpongeBob's place unfortunately Gary and
mr. worm hated each other
the snail was certainly not ready to see
that he was actually living with a mrs.
worm who was pregnant and had many
babies the two pets started fighting and
mrs. worm had to leave leaving her
babies with spongebob he asked everyone
in the neighborhood if they wanted to
adopt them but unfortunately no one was
really interested even spongebob
accidentally hurt them when they ended
up in the street after Larry lobster
tried to eat them these poor little
babies had lost their mother and they
were badly treated by everyone else in
this episode mr. crabs ended up being
interested in the baby
only when he learned that they were
worth a lot of money and he told them to
his customers like they were just
objects and they call this a happy
ending these worms shouldn't live with
people who are just looking for glory
but with a longing family every living
creature deserves a better treatment
procrastination you probably don't
understand why this episode was
inappropriate but it actually was if you
look at the deleted scene in this
episode spongebob had to work on an
essay for his driving class this is why
you had to stay home and work hard but
he kept procrastinating and for
estimating it has been hours and you
didn't do anything while he was in his
house punch Bob looked at people having
fun outside his window there was a fair
people were riding a roller coaster
jellyfish were playing badminton leaving
Gary was enjoying this beautiful day
and then there was Patrick putting
sunscreen on sandy and inviting his
friend to join them but spongebob went
back at his desk and thought about how
important this essay was if he ever
wanted to get his driver's license this
is where we saw a real-life footage of a
car crash spongebob fans don't know if
this scene was deleted because it looked
like Patrick was unhooking Sandy's
bikini or because we saw a car crash its
final in spongebob can't drive because
he is only a cartoon character but
seeing it in real life might be too much
no matter what this whole scene is not
appropriate for kids and we totally
understand why they decided to delete it
but we still wish that grown-ups could
see the whole episode the Battle of
bikini bottom Patrick and SpongeBob
we're happy to have their own best
friend shirts but then everything turned
out wrong when they switched places and
were given the wrong signals they were
kicked out of the mall and mad people
who were really interested in historical
battles this is why they decided to join
them to reenact the Battle of Bikini
Bottom the city was divided in those who
always wanted to clean their hands and
those who had better things to do this
is how the two best friends ended up
being divided into two teams they
started fighting to know what was better
being clean or being dirty
spongebob stole his friends nose and he
stole his eyeball Patrick put sand in
his friend's pants and spongebob gave
him a pedicure
then they started fighting with morning
breath toothpaste armpit sweat and
deodorant but as the kept saying the
words dirty and filthy and how much they
liked it grown-ups could think of a
whole different meaning that's because
being dirty or filthy can be really
inappropriate for kids while it is
really enjoyable for some adults and in
this battle they were
we fighting about people who are more
proof this alternative definition of
these words gives a whole new meaning to
the story but as long as kids don't
understand it we think it is okay for
them to watch this episode I'm with
stupid this time Patrick surprised
spongebob while he was cleaning his
house that's not the kind of thing that
he usually does but his best friend
quickly found out what was going on he
received a message from his parents
saying that they were coming over
tomorrow
the starfish said that his parents
thought that he is dumber than a sack of
diapers and this is why he really wanted
to impress them
spongebob tried to help him by acting
dumber than he ever was before so
Patrick would look smarter compared to
him that sounded like a great idea but
it is rare to see these two friends
actually being smart to look stupid
spongebob wore a protective helmet which
could be considered insulting to those
who really need one spongebob was just
being funny but Patrick took things way
too far he started making fun of his
friends by saying mean things about him
and what he usually does every day like
living in a pineapple dressing like that
or simply being a sponge
spongebob didn't think that it was funny
anymore but Patrick didn't care he just
took advantage of the situation to make
himself look better
he didn't even learn his lesson at the
end of the episode no matter what we
think that no kid should ever think that
making fun of someone whether they are
disabled or not is a good thing to do
one course meal in this episode one of
the characters tried to do the most
terrible thing you could ever imagine it
all started while mr. Krabs was relaxing
in a bath full of money he didn't know
that plankton was planning to enter the
Krusty Krab with explosives once again
he was there to find the secret recipe
of the krabby patty and the owner of the
restaurant and spongebob were ready to
fight back but plankton finally caught
them and he was ready to torture mr.
Krabs to get the formula spongebob
accidentally revealed where the secret
was hiding but he quickly left when he
saw pearl after all we all know that
whales eat plankton plankton was so
terrified and disappointed that he
stayed at home started having nightmares
and became depressed he was not even
interested in the formula anymore not
only was pearl terrifying but the poor
plankton did something worse he tried to
kill himself by lying in the middle of
the road and get rolled over he even
asked spongebob to kill him this is the
worst thing that they could ever show to
children when something goes wrong you
should never think
this kind of ending did you see any
other inappropriate episodes of
Spongebob Squarepants
don't be try to tell us what it is in
the comment section down below we love
to hear what do you think and that's it
for 10 SpongeBob SquarePants episodes
that weren't for kids for more stories
like this make sure you watch 10 the
loud house episodes that weren't for
kids thanks for watching
[Music]